hello everyone this game was a
suggestion from a subscriber and I'm
glad it was it's a quite an interesting
game it was played in 1981 it was the
Edinburgh Club Championship played in
Edinburgh Scotland of course and the
game is played between GF Chandler and
Richard kina both players were rated
around 2000 I believe as I couldn't
really find any information about him
and if any of you are able to find a
photo of mr. G of Chandler or do share
in the comments so I can update the
thumbnail until then mr. Hudak I will
claim the glory for this game in the
thumbnail so let's see the game G of
Chandler is white and Richard kina has
the black pieces we have E for c6 d4 and
d5 the caro-kann defense he 5 the
advanced variation and Bishop to a5
Knight to c3 e 6 and now G for Bishop to
g6 and 90 G to e2 not going for h4
immediately we have c5 Bishop to e3 9th
to c6 and D captures on c5 and Knight
captures on e5 and the black has a very
strong here central pawn structure white
will be white is well black is a bit
better here and well white has to be
pretty careful here if he plays a move
like for example this Knight is
attacking g4 if he plays a move like h3
he gets nice to f3 with checkmate so he
definitely doesn't want to play a move
like that
so after 95 mr. Chandler played at night
to d4 and now the Queen and the night
are protecting f3 and also the queen is
protecting g4 we have worked the c8 and
Bishop to b5 would check and Knight to
c6 and here we have the first pin of the
game
Queen to e2 Knight to f6 we have
queenside castle by Chandler and Bishop
to e7 h4 we have h v f3 Knight to d7 and
the G captures on h5 and this is
definitely the critical position of the
game if black continued this game
Bishop captures on h5 everything would
be perfectly okay and black would
continue this game being better but mr.
King off decided to play rook captures
on h5 and this is where his troubles
begin we have rook h2g one now while
putting a rock on a very nice G file
also eyeing this bishop and if the
bishop moves this g7 pawn
so again probably the best the best idea
here would be to play something like
night to f8 or even Bishop to h7 would
be okay but mr. keener played Knight
captures on d4 we have Bishop captures
on d4 now attacking this g7 pawn and we
have Queen to c7 blacks idea is that if
if mr. Chandler captures this pawn on g7
he will continue with for example Bishop
captures and c5 but at M pawn the rook
and everything and everything should be
okay
although this would be a terrible
blunder as well but after Queen to c7
Chandler doesn't really really bother
himself with this g7 pawn and he plays
the immediate rook captures on g6 a
similar idea
Karpov played in his game in his
immortal game against Apollo we have F
captures and g6 grabbing the rook isn't
really the best move but well this
position is so bad for black that no
moves are good F character Sen g6 was
played and we have Queen captures on e6
and well what do you do here probably
something like King to f8 comes to mind
but again there are really no good moves
here mr. king of tried rook to f5
probably with the idea of getting this
rook to be able to help the king with
King with rook f7 and rook to f8 mr.
Chandler played a knife captors on d5
and this comes with a temple on the
Queen and also is now threatening Queen
captures on e7 with checkmate so Queen
to d8 is played and we have Queen
captures on g6 with Czech rock to f7
defending if King to have faith this
would also
be a force checkmate pretty simple one
with Bishop captures on g7 King to g8
Bishop to h6 check King to h8 and Queen
to g7 with checkmate
so after this Queen to g6 check mr.
keener played rook to f7 we have rook to
e1 now pinning this Bishop on e7 and
this is our third pin of the game
already we have kink to f8 Queen to h7
now with the threat of Queen to h8
checkmate
so the king has to go back King to e8 we
have Queen to g8 with the check well
Knight can't come to a fate as it's bent
bishop can't defend it's been formed
Rock anyone so rook to f8 we have Queen
to g7 capturing the pawn and now
threatening rook captures on e7 with
Czech and after the Queen recaptures
Queen captures on e7 with checkmate so
only move two defenders
rook to f7 and now mr. Chandler plays
Queen back to g8 with check only move
rook to f8 and now we have Knight to f6
and this is checkmate and look at all of
these pieces defending the black king
this knight is pinned from the bishop
this bishop is pin from the rook this
rook cannot capture as it's bent from
the Queen everything is pinned and the
wall a beautiful a beautiful ending by
mr. G of Chandler and I really think
that well the quote above the board
really fits the video as the pin truly
is mightier than the sword
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it once again if any of you are
able to find a photo of mr. Chandler do
share in the comments as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon